>> AS A MOMMA OF 4 SONS, OKAY --
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I HAVE FOUR SONS.
I DON'T THINK I WOULD WANT THE
TEACHER TO BE ARRESTED.
IF MY SONS WERE 17 YEARS OLD AND
THE TEACHER WAS 22 YEARS OLD,
BECAUSE, LET ME ASK YOU, LIKE
YOU SAY, AT 17 YEARS OLD --
>> TO BE ABLE TO FINISH SCHOOL,
THAT'S WHY YOU DON'T WANT HER
ARRESTED?
FINISH HIGH SCHOOL FIRST THEN
YOU CAN TAKE HER.
>> YES.
AT 17, YOU WOULD HAVE LAID WITH
YOUR 22-YEAR-OLD TEACHER.
>> I WOULD HAVE LAID WITH
ANYTHING THAT SAID YES!
THAT'S WHY I SHOULD NOT BE IN
CHARGE AT THAT AGE WHEN IT COMES
TO ADULTS.
LOOK, ONE OF THE REASONS I
BELIEVE WE ARE ADULTS IS BECAUSE
WE SHOULD PROTECT CHILDREN.
>> YES.
AND I THINK IT BREAKS THAT
CONTRACT WHEN ADULTS ARE ALLOWED
>> I WANT TO PROTECT MY CHILDREN
BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT I WANT
THAT TEACHER TO GO TO PRISON.
IT WOULD BE A WOMAN-TO-WOMAN
CONVERSATION LIKE, YOU SHOWED
HIM WHAT?
GIRL!
NEXT TIME MAKE SURE YOU GIVE HIM
AN A.
HE'S NOT DOING GOOD IN SPANISH,
SO, OKAY...
>> LET'S SWITCH IT TO YOU HAVE
FOUR DAUGHTERS --
>> LOCK HIS ASS UP!